but first of how do we solve this
problem of we win the election but we
don't get to be President
yeah because this has happened twice now
yeah since 2000 Al Gore and now Hillary
and it seems to be happening to one
party only us only Democrats right which
is of course the way they would want it
and you kind of can't blame him for that
but how do we fix that well I'm in the
process now writing an article that says
Lee there's a simple solution to it we
have to just abolish the Electoral
College it's not but they're not gonna
go along with that and cuz isn't that
isn't that a constitutional amendment
requires a constitutionally that is some
heavy lifting but all right so it so it
involves heavy lift right let's lift
heavy let's lift let's do it right you
know yeah we got to do it yeah I mean
it's funny cuz you know always Donald
Trump opposite land he kept saying the
election is rigged it is rigged in his
favor yeah not just that but when you
think about the the election is on
Tuesday instead of a holiday like most
countries poor people can't just say hey
I'm taking off for the rest of the
afternoon and voting and long lines in
urban places of course gutting the
Voting Rights Act with a eliminated
polling places all of this stuff it's a
completely really come up with ideas the
need for photo ID to show who you are
you know there's always been an element
in our voting system that you had to
prove who you were but they've only come
up recently with this notion these more
restrictive and prescriptive things that
have a negative impact on those people
who are less likely to vote for
Republicans and they also happen to
affect disproportionately people of
color okay so that's it seems like if
one place you can just pop in and vote
and the other place there's lines for
six hours that that would be a violation
of the Equal Protection Clause of the
Constitution against the Equal
Protection Clause of the Constitution
and goes against the fundamental thing
that binds us as Americans the ability
of the people to decide who their
leaders are who their leader is going to
be and what policies those leaders will
will shape right now the Republican
Party has put itself on the wrong side
of history here you know 50 years from
now people are gonna look back and say
this is the party that stood for denying
people the right to vote Democrats want
it now yeah I don't and we fight others
I'll be dead
what we fight them out we fought on
while I was at the Justice Department
and that's going to be a big change
that's gonna be a big change I did a
whole bunch of stuff to protect the
right to know you do the next Attorney
General I suspect will not share up my
values right
you